[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans sens public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes comme tous les
jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité avec deux thèmes
seulement et donc du temps pour nos
invités experts pour creuser ces sujets
voici le sommaire de ce 9 janvier qui
restera dans la chronique de la 5e
République comme le jour de la
nomination du plus jeune premier
ministre de notre histoire à 34 ans
Gabriel Atal succède à elliizabeth borne
qui l'a remercier pour sa loyauté tu as
la détermination et l'énergie pour mener
une équipe et porter les projets
nécessaires pour notre
pays tu as aussi cette volonté de tenir
de respecter la parole
donnée le plus dur commence pour Atal le
super communiant comment va at-il
imprimer sa marque et sortir de l'image
de celui qui doit tout à Emmanuel Macron
on en débat juste après ces titres et
puis dans 45 minutes cette question
l'année 2024 permettra-t-elle à
l'Ukraine de gagner la guerre contre
l'envahisseur russe la contreoffensive
lancée au printemps est un échec les
missiles de Moscou s'abattent de nouveau
sur les grandes villes du pays et le
soutien occidental s'effrite comment
volodimir Zelenski et ses généraux
peuvent-ils stir de ce qui ressemble de
plus en plus à une impasse réponse dans
45 minutes donc mais d'abord le portrait
du nouveau Premier ministre avec Jérôme
Rabier c'est seul et à pied que Gabriel
Atal est arrivé à Matignon salement
poliment les forces de sécurité dans son
nouveau costume de Premier ministre à
seulement 34 ans il devient le plus
jeune chef de gouvernement français de
l'histoire une précocité qu'il brandit
comme un étendard assumant laaffiliation
avec Emmanuel Macron le plus jeune
président de la République de l'histoire
nomme le plus jeune premier ministre de
l'histoire je ne veux y voir qu'un seul
symbole celui de l'audace et du
mouvement du PS où il adhère en 2007 au
petit cercle des premiers marcheurs qui
s'engagent derrière Emmanuel Macron en
2016 son ascension en coulisse était
déjà éclairire mais en 2017 dans la
foulée de l'élection de son mentor il
passe aussi à la lumière devenant député
des hautes scènes à 28
un an plus tard en 2018 il entre au
gouvernement comme secrétaire d'État en
charge du service national universel à
29 ans déjà un record de précocité sous
la 5e République un gouvernement qu' ne
quittera plus en devenant même le
porte-parole en 2020 un poste exposé qui
le fait connaître du grand public après
un passage au budget c'est l'été dernier
qu'il obtient un ministère autant rêver
que redouter celui de l'éducation
nationale il faut en revenir à des
choses simples le respect du professeur
et de son autorité la maîtrise des
savoirs fondamentaux le respect de la
laïcité r Grenel il imprime son style et
son tempo médiatique en lançant à la
rentrée l'interdiction de laba puis
s'engageant sur le dossier du
harcèlement scolaire un passage trop
court pour en faire un bilan mais il
promet de faire de l'éducation une
priorité de sa nouvelle fonction dont il
fixe déjà la méthode mettre en place des
actions fortes concrètes sans tabou
vérité agir sans attendre voilà ce que
sera mon action à la tête du
gouvernement de la France une doctrine
mise en pratique dès cet après-midi en
se rendant immédiatement après la
passation de pouvoir dans le Pas de
Calais au chevet des sinistrés des
inondations pour montrer sa volonté
d'être au plus près des Français sur le
terrain on débat donc autour de la
personnalité de Gabriel Atal quelle sera
la marge de manœuvre du nouveau Premier
ministre comment peut-il imprimer sa
marque à quoi pourrait ressembler son
premier gouvernement et on répond à
toutes ces questions avec adéaï
zulviarpatiic bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes directrice générale de BVA France
Florent vadiillot bonsoir et bienvenue
le président de l'éérie et vous êtes
enseignant à sciencecesp Stéphane Vernet
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste rédacteur en chef délégué et
directeur de la rédaction euh West
France à Paris et puis auteur de ce
livre déjeuner secret dans les coulisses
de la réforme des retraites aux éditions
West France je l'ai lu pendant mes
vacances c'était passionnant merci du
cadeau Émilie zapalski bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes spécialiste en
communication politique élitorialiste
pour sens public allez je vous ai
demandé de vous prêter un petit jeu
premier tour de table pour qualifier le
choix de Gabriel hatal en un mot adélaï
zulfiarpaic quel est votre choix
judicieux judicieux je le note en même
temps judicieux Florent vadiot attendu
attendu Stéphane Vernet audacieux Émilie
malin c'est plutôt positif quand même
allez on rentre dans dans le détail
pourquoi c'est judicieux euh c'est
judicieux pour pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que Gabriel Atal est une
personnalité montante appréciée de une
partie importante des français quand je
dis importante c'est surtout dans le
spectre politique que ça recouvre on
verra plus tard mais l' apprécié à
gauche comme à droite y compris or RN
par par une partie des électeurs il a un
certain nombre de qualités sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir et puis il
est sans doute celui qui incarne le plus
aujourd'hui le en même temps originel
d'Emmanuel Macron ce qui a fait sa force
qui a fait son ce pourquoi il a été élu
en grande partie je pense notamment à
son premier mandat et qui s'est perdu au
fil du temps et donc aujourd'hui Gabriel
Atal est peut-être en mesure de
d'incarner justement ces deux jambes
gauche et droite du président alors
est-ce que pour autant ça sera suffisant
pour redonner un souffle un nouveau
souffle à ce mandat j'en doute un petit
peu mais en tout cas on va dire que dans
la configuration qui était la sienne je
pense que c'était sans doute le meilleur
choix qu'il pouvait faire ça on y
reviendra évidemment sur ce second
souffle ou nouveau
souffle espérer pourquoi est-ce attendu
vous aviez d'ailleurs dit quand on
prépare l'émission attendu et dérant
voilà j' endu mais déroutant un seot
vousê je me suis plié aux règles attendu
parce que ça fait depuis déjà plusieurs
jours que le nom est de plus en plus
récurrent qu'il a fait une entrée
extrêmement remarquable et remarqué
comme ministre de l'éducation nationale
qui n'est pas neutre dans un
gouvernement peut-être aussi parce que
je suis lecteur de sud-ouest et que
quand on avait la une c'était qui pour
Matignon et on voyait Gabriel àal donc
le message était subliminal et puis
déroutant parce que en réalité quel est
la leçon politique ellisabeth borne
a-t-elle échoué sur une stratégie propre
je ne le crois pas elle a suivi celle
que le Président de la République
voulait était-elle moins bien placée que
Gabriel Atal pour mener des discussions
avec l'Assemblée nationale la preuve a
montré que sur la loi immigration elle a
réussi à aboutir et quel est le au prix
Dee d'une fracture interne à la majorité
relative mais bon la loi est passé la
loi est passée et avec une négociation
politique et enfin quel est le le bilan
quelle est l'énergie nouvelle que
gabrielal va apporter au-delà de ce qui
est pour l'instant une série de coût
politique médiatique je ne sais pas quel
est son bilan en fait en 7 ans de
présence au gouvernement donc je j'ai
hâte de voir ce qu'il va imprimer comme
méthode à matinon ça effectivement c'est
une des critiques assez justifié quand
même c'estd qu'il a tellement enchaîné
les postes qu'il n'est pas resté assez
longtemps pour avoir un bilan Stéphane
Vernet vous disiez audacieux de la part
du président pourquoi oui aux parce que
parce que on est dans un contexte
périlleux 2024 c'est quand même l'année
de tous les danger du point de vue
international du point de vue de
l'équilibre des comptes publs on a une
échéance électorale avec les européennes
qui sont des élections de m-imandat qui
compte énormément pour le président de
la République et qui qui sont un gros
enjeu politique et en fait par rapport à
ça il y avait la volonté de de de créer
un surceau une rupture parce qu'il
aurait pu garder ellisabeth bornne qui a
qui a rempli la mission que le Président
de la République lui avait fixé en fait
elle a pas de démérité elle a fait le
job il y avait pas de raison de changer
de Premier ministre si ce n'est pour
affronter notamment ces échéances
électorales les européennes et il fait
le choix pourquoi je dis audacieux parce
qu'il fait le choix de quelqu'un qui est
très très jeune donc c'est c'est un
c'est un Gabriel Atal il a beau être
jeune c'est un animal politique il est
brillant il a du talent il n'empêche que
il a que 34 ans il aurait pu choisir
quelqu'un d'autre et en fait il y a je
pense qu'il a il y a la volonté à la
fois de de montrer pour Emmanuel Macron
que c'est toujours lui qui a les clés du
camion qu'il est pas il est il est il a
beau avoir un pouvoir qui est dans une
impasse il est pas il y a pas une
impuissance du pouvoir et il choisit
effectivement quelqu'un de très jeune
inexpérimenté par bien des aspect mais
qui en même temps il a eu plusieurs
postes c'est vrai et dans le dernier on
peut pas dire qu'il soit resté
suffisamment longtemps pour avoir un
vrai bilan n'empêche que ce qu'il a
montrer en étant ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est qu'il était capable de
prendre des décisions et de les assumer
et des décisions fortes sur la baaya sur
le harcèlement scolaire il d'imprimer
dans l'opinion
surtout on y reviendra sur sur sur sur
l'image qu'il a mais au-delà de ça c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a 34 ans est
capable de dire moi je prends des
décisions je les je les assume je les et
je vais au bout alors que beaucoup de
ses prédécesseurs ou beaucoup d'autres
ministres en fait finalement ne
décidaient pas c'est-à-dire que ils
réagissaient dans l'urgence ils
expliquaient il remettait des éléments
de contexte mais il prenait pas de
décision très fortes et lui il a pris
plusieurs décisions fortes et je pense
que c'est aussi ça le le le le le Paris
du président de la République de
l'aodace encore de l'aodace toujours de
l'audace et la France est sauvé oui il
ais il a repris il a repris c'était une
citation il il a repris ce terme audace
et mouvement c'est les deux termes que
que Gabriel hatal a utilisé lors de son
discours de passation de pouvoir vous
dites malin oui parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est le changement
pour les figures mais dans la continuité
parce que comme vous l'avez dit c'est le
meilleur porteur du en même temps donc
quelque part il va continuer cette
espèce de d'équilibre difficile du en
même temps et surtout moi je pense que
c'est malin vis-à-vis des élections
européennne qui arrive et on a entendu
Emmanuel Macron désigner son adversaire
dans les vœux enfin à mot cacher le
rassemblement national et on voit bien
ceent on voit le match des trentenaires
on voit ces deux figures qui émergent
ces hommes politiques de la nouvelle
génération Jord Bardella Gabriel Attal
on a l'impression que c'est un animal
politique qui peut faire le poids
vis-à-vis de ce candidat de cette tête
de liste aux Européennes et là on sent
que le quinena il prend en tout cas ce
sens-là vis-à-vis du RN parce que
globalement sur le fond on voit pas
tellement ce que ça va apporter à part
cette personnalité assez étonnante et
détonnante ouais Gabriel hatal qui a
réservé son premier déplacement de de
Premier ministre au au Pas de Calais
région multiinondée depuis depuis des
mois je vous propose une séquence il est
avec une buraliste qui est victime de
ces inondations le le message il est
assez clair je suis proche des Français
toujours important d'avoir des capteurs
ah oui sur le terrain qui de voir c'est
ce qu'on décide d'en haut euh arrive
jusqu'au jusqu'au premier concerné mais
vraiment je sais que c'est dur à
entendre moi je viens là vous vivez ça
depuis des mois je sais que c'est dur à
entendre mais mais ne vous démoralisez
pas non non et vous êtes l'incarnation
de cette France qui travaille laborieuse
qui se lève tout le matin pour
accueillir des clients pour faire vivre
tout un village oui tout à fait vous
baisserez pas les bras ça se
sent ça se sent on sera là pour certain
mais bon un peu de démagogie en même
temps c'est un homme politique à dél de
zulfi karpaic c'est c'est le premier de
la classe quand même qu'il a enfin le
premier de la classe populaire on va
dire ça comme ça que qu'Emmanuel Macron
a choisi parce que c'est le plus
populaire des ministres dans dans dans
l'opinion est-ce que pour vous c'est
vraiment un élément important voire très
important du choix d'Emmanuel Macron
dans dans la dans les raisons qui ont
mené Emmanuel Macron à ce choix je je ne
sais pas si c'est ce qui a conduit
Emmanuel Macron à faire ce choix en tout
cas c'est certain que par rapport à
l'ensemble des ministre et même
globalement à l'ensemble des
personnalités politiques actuelles qu'on
parle de du gouvernement de l'opposition
des oppositions il est vraiment une
figure montante on a vu d'ailleurs sa sa
popularité monter de manière vraiment
exponentielle depuis qu'il a été nommé
ministre de l'éducation nationale en
juillet alors justement il vient de la
gauche on l'a vu dans le portrait il a
été militant socialiste euh mais est-ce
qu'il a aussi beaucoup de soutien à
droite notamment grâce à ce qu'il a
annoncé Rud Grenel exactement c'est
assez frappant je je regardeis avant de
venir comment est-ce que ce ce
s'articulait sa sa sa popularité il est
à la fois la deuxième personnalité
politique préférée je mets de côté le
président derrière Édouard Philippe des
sympathisants de de la majorité mais il
est également la 4è personnalité
préférée des sympathisants PS ce qui est
pas mal il est devant des personnalités
comme Christian tobira Bernard casenuve
il est il se classe aussi très bien chez
les sympathisants LR donc il est
globalement apprécié de l'ensemble du
spectre politique et on voit bien quand
on regarde un peu dans les enquêtes
d'opinion ce qui nous est dit que
effectivement les sympathisants de
gauche reconnaissent c encore cette
affiliation au au au PS et on voit que
les électeurs de droite ont apprécié son
passage au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et cette volonté notamment de
restaurer l'autorité on voyit dans l'ex
vous avez montré le rapport au
professeurs le respect des professeurs
l'autorité il y a eu effectivement le
l'interdiction de la baaya donc il a
réussi pour l'instant encore une fois il
arrive à à séduire entre guillemets à la
fois une partie de l'électorat de gauche
et l'électorat de droite ouais mais mais
les valeurs de gauche ces valeurs
d'origine on va dire ça comme ça Florent
vadiot on les a allez j'all dire par non
peu entendu pendant le débat sur
l'immigration il a été discret Gabriel
j'étais en train de d'essayer de me
souvenir s'il y avait eu une
intervention forte de la part de Gabriel
Atal sur la réforme des retraites
j'essaie de me souvenir aussi donc en
fait il a géré une r politique un
capital politique qui est fondé sur
l'indistinction parce qu'effectivement
comme il vient de la gauche on peut
estimer que il est une personnalité de
gauche
bon comme il a pris un des thèmes qui
étaient employés par la droite et qu'il
a tranché sur des questions qui étaient
pas non plus d'une difficulté majeur
mais il a tranché il est identifié à
droite je pense que matigon va l'obliger
à sortir de l'indistinction parce que
sujets sur tous les sujets il devra donc
porter une politique sur laquelle il a
été parfois extrêmement discret et donc
je je je j'aimerais savoir par par
exemple ce qu'il a pensé de la loi
immigration parce que je n'ai pas
souvenance d'une seule interview sur
laquelle il est il soit venu en soutien
de sa première ministre ou de Gérald
armanin ou dans plusieurs interviews
Gabriel hatal avant d'être nommé à
Matignon avait déclaré je dois tout à
Emmanuel Macron alors il l'a pasodit en
ses mots mais il a quand même rendu
hommage au président de la République un
peu un passage obligé lors de son
discours de passation de pouvoir avec
ellisabeth borne écoutez mesdames et
messieurs avant de conclure je veux
avoir à nouveau une pensée pour le
président de la République lui redire
toute ma gratitude toute ma
fidélité Stéphane Vernet quand on dit ça
je doit tout à Emmanuel Macron qu'on
devient premier ministre et que on est
un animal politique ambitieux tout le
monde le
dit qui donc va vouloir imposer sa sa
marque il y a là un défi quand même très
compliqué comment va-t-il faire pour
sortir de une critique moi j'étais à un
moment vous savez on cherche des titres
entre nous un moment j'ai dit tiens on
pourrait faire Gabriel Atal la voix de
son maître ce qui était très dur donc on
l'a pas choisi mais vous voyez ce que je
veux dire ce cette critique là elle va
elle va apparaître assez vite non alors
c'est c'est un c'est un fidèle à la
première heure en fait il a il a rejoint
les macronistes dès 2016 donc oui il a
il a il il a commencé il a été d'abord
militant au Parti socialiste du Parti
socialiste il a commencé au cabinet de
marieel Touren mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est loin c'est c'était il y a
longtemps donc l'ancrage à gauche de
Gabriel Atal moi je je suis pas je suis
pas je suis pas certain le le l'espèce
d'en même temps construit par le
Président de la République au fil des
années je pense que plus on avance et
plus il penche à droite et je pense qu'
que Gabriel Atal est dans le est dans le
est dans le dans la même trajectoire la
proximité elle est là après si la
question c'est comment imprimer sa
marque c'est ça question voilà alors moi
je pense que c'est une question de
personnalité et tout le monde est en
train de dire oui il arrivera pas et
cetera ça va être une marionnette il
sera au service du Président vous avez
des éditorialistes ou des des des
commentateurs qui disent ben en fait
c'est un Emmanuel Macron bis une espèce
de doublure il sera transparent moi je
crois pas je crois que je je crois je
pour pour avoir fréquenté assez
régulièrement ces dernières années
d'avoir rencontré à de nombreuses
reprises Gabriel Atal je pense qu'il a
beaucoup de personnalité et que et que
ce sera pas juste un un clone du
président de la République je pense
qu'il est très fidèle et il sera comme
il était fidèle à comme il était très
fidèle à à Jean Castex ou à Elisabeth
borne Jean Castex on rappelle qu'il a
été son
porte-parole av une vra proximité enfin
voilà et et il a fait preuve de la même
vis-àvis d'Élisabeth borne et je pense
qu'il est il est il est tout dévoué au
président de la République mais ça ne
veut pas dire que ce sera juste une
marionnette au service du de de
d'Emmanuel Macron je pense qu'il y a il
y a je pense qu'il a la possibilité et
les qualités nécessaires et la
personnalité
pour imprimer sa sa propre marque après
on verra l'usage ou alors tout le monde
en tout cas il aura un atout c'est son
son talent son art de la communication
et pas qui c'est votre expertise l'une
de vos expertises est-ce que vous aussi
vous nous dites c'est quand même un
communiquant en repère oui oui il faut
le dire Gabriel depuis ses premiers pas
dans la politique globalement c'est une
bête de communication un exemple juste
avec les réseaux sociaux puisque c'est
quand même le monde moderne he de la com
en novembre 2023 donc ministre de
l'éducation nationale il crée un canal
WhatsApp pour qui est dédié aux familles
et aux élèves et c'est une première pour
un ministre de l'éducation nationale les
parents peuvent pas poser des questions
faut pas pousser quand même mais ils
peuvent lire les publications qui sont
très très très régulièrement faites
jusqu'à hier hier il y avait encore donc
une information sur un temps
d'apprentissage du respect de l'autre et
de l'empathie qui est mis en place dans
les écoles en fait la jeunesse de
Gabriel hatal ça lui permet d'être
davantage à l'aise dans les réseaux
sociaux et plus généralement dans les
médias qu'aucun autre membre du
gouvernement même si on a eu des
Jean-Baptiste jebaris si vous vous
souvenez ministre des transport qui
était très présent sur TikTok est-ce que
vous auriez jusqu'à dire que qu'il est
obsédé par la communication euh je pense
qu'il a compris que ça lui donnait
vraiment de la personnalité euh et ces
opérations sont souvent très réussies on
en a parlé la mise en scène de ces
décisions très fermes sur le harcèlement
à annoncé dès l'été de sa nomination
avec au passage un témoignage poignant
c'est la séquence émogon émotion sur sa
propre histoire on a euussi il l'avait
fait notamment dans l'émission 7 à 8
tout à fait l'interdiction de la baaya
aussi à l'automne le plan choc des
savoirs après nos piteux résultats dans
le baromètre PISA l'expérimentation de
l'uniforme en fait l'homme et c'est rare
en macronie il sait parler au français
euh il comprend ou en tout cas il donne
l'impression de comprendre ce que les
Français vivent au quotidien résultat et
on l'a dit il s'est vite Issé parmi les
personnalités politiques préférées des
Français talonant l'indétronable Édouard
Philippe il fait même partie attention
du trio avec qui les citoyens français
préféraent boire une bière c'est le beer
test
j'adore voilà et il est toujours au côté
de l'ancien Premier ministre et de
Marine Le Pen autre à tout et on en a
parlé aussi c'est payant pour Emmanuel
Macron il assume complètement le en même
temps capable de séduire la gauche d'où
il vient et la droite à qui il s'est
parlé avec les fameux mots magiques ABA
uniforme autorité peu importe aussi si
les mesures qu'il lance ne sont pas trop
suivies dans le temps on parlerit de
bilan on sait pas trop comme son plan
antifraude qu'il avait lancé quand il
était ministre des comptes publques ou
alors peu importe s'il traite pas
finalement les problèmes de fond il y a
quand même un problème de d'attractivité
pour les métiers de l'enseignement et
éducation nationale ce qui compte pour
lui c'est moins le savoir-faire que le
faire savoir alors là on a été plutôt
dans le positif quel revers peut-il y
avoir à cette hyper communication le
risque principal c'est que le grand chef
même s'il est plus dans la course pour
2027 le jalouse un peu trop on a
l'impression qu'Emmanuel Macron a dû
lutter contre sa propre nature pour
choisir un homme politique plus jeune
plus populaire que lui une figure qui
brille déjà beaucoup et qui risque
évidemment de lui faire de l'ombre mais
il semblerait que c'est le prix à payer
pour lancer ce deuxième quinquena qui
après 1 an et demi peine décidément à
démarrer alors vous vous nous l'avez dit
à la question du bilan on va on va faire
un focus pendant quelques minutes sur
son passage éclair R Grenel donc au
ministère de l'Éducation Nationale 4
mois et on en parle tout de suite avec
Adrien Brachet qui est journaliste
éducation à Marianne contributeur à la
Fondation Jean jorz bonsoir Adrien
Brachet merci d'avoir accepté notre
notre invitation on peut dire ce soir
que ce ministère aura été ou n'aura été
qu'un trempelin qu'est-ce que vous
retenez-vous de son passage éclair alors
disons que je je rejoint ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure sur l'aspect de la
communication disons que euh après un
papendia qui était jugé assez timoré
assez prudent euh dès son arrivée
Gabriel hatal a su répondre à une forme
de de de demande de de de l'opinion
sur l'autorité des professeurs faire
moter sur la laïcité avec la question de
laabaya donc il a tout de suite appuyé
d'une certaine manière sur des touches
de piano qui fonctionnent très bien euh
pour les Français euh il a su aussi
avoir un poids politique par exemple
pour arraché en décembre à la dernière
minute des postes d'enseignants qui
auraient dû être supprimés euh pour
pouvoir mettre en place ces différentes
mesures du du choc des savoirs donc
là-dessus il il a su se faire une place
on va dire en revanche derrière cette
cette peut-être cette bouliniie
d'annonce et de et et de présence
médiatique qu'il a eu euh on peut pas
dire qu'il est réellement un bilan en 4
mois ou en 5 mois euh c'est une
gigantesque machine éducation nationale
c'est plus de 12 millions d'élèves 1,2
million de personnels affectés donc on
peut pas en 4 5 mois avir un vrai bilan
euh et y compris sur les mesures de son
choc des savoirs certaines sont un peu
contesté notamment par la recherche
scientifique on sait pas encore
exactement comment elles vont se mettre
en place comment les moyens vont être
distribués donc donc donc il y a encore
beaucoup d'incertitude et il y a surtout
un gros chantier qui devait être traité
en janvier qui finalement n'a pas encore
été traité du fait de ce départ à
Matignon qui va probablement l'être
prochainement mais qui est un un un un
dossier central qui est la question du
recrutement et de la formation des
enseignants il devait y avoir des
annonces en janvier et comme ça a été
très bien dit sur le plateau euh on ne
peut pas résoudre les problèmes de
l'éducation nationale sans résoudre le
problème de l'attractivité de la
profession je rappelle qu'au dernier
concours enseignant il y avait encore
près de 3000 postes non pourvus restez
avec nous Adrien j'ai encore une
question à vous poser Florent vadiillot
il a dit Gabriel Atal tout à l'heure
qu'il allait emmener avec lui la cause
de l'école à à Matignon est-ce que ça
veut dire que celui ou celle qui va lui
succéder sera sous surveillance ce que
je veux dire ah je je pense que le
portefeuille du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale va être extrêmement complexe à
gérer d'abord parce que le nom sera
extrêmement attendu très scruté ça sera
évidemment pas un profil papend on sera
plus proche d'un Michel d'un Jean-Michel
Blanquer et puis parce que précisément
le départ assez précoce de Gabriel Atal
sur des promesses devront nécessairement
être tenues dans les temps et donc le
premier ministre aura à mon avis à cœur
de porter la poursuite de son discours
et d'autant que ça c'est un thème qui se
répercute immédiatement sur les famille
française et donc s'il arrive à à
marquer de son empreinte le thème
éducatif
il aura réussi une certaine chose et on
pourra le créditer d'une continuité en
tout cas dans dans la volonté tout ça ce
sont des S évidemment on est encore
c'est normal c'est son premier jour à
matinon alors des
hypothèses Adrien Brachet dernier mot
que comment ça se passait avec les
syndicats que disaient les syndicats
d'ailleurs s'il y a une méthode àal de
la méthode
àal bon alors il y avait plusieurs avis
en fonction des des syndicats bon
beaucoup ont été ass critique de son
plan sur le choc des savoirs considérant
que le le le les les mesures qu'il
prenaent n'allaient pas forcément dans
le sens de ce que la recherche
considérait comme étant les bonnes
solution néanmoins certains ont été
satisfaits des posts qu'il a pu arracher
en décembre dernier et notamment je
parlais tout à l'heure à des à des chefs
de des syndicalistes chefs sur les
questions d'éducation à l'UNSA et qui me
disait qu' lui reconnaissait quand même
d'avoir cette capacité à toujours
dialoguer à se rendre disponible c'estàd
à la fin il penche pas forcément dans le
sens des syndicats mais il lui
reconnaissent une capacité à discuter à
être à l'écoute ce qu'avait peut-être un
peu moins réussi Jean-Michel Blanquer
merci beaucoup Adrien Brachet pour cette
intervention on va on va vous envoyer
des livres pour votre
bibliothèque peut-être celui de Stéphane
vernis ce sera voilà va vous aider à
remplir cette bibliothèque désespérément
vide derrière vous je sais pas si on l'a
bien on l'a bien vu bref pardon de cette
mauvaise blague euh merci en tout cas
d'avoir participé à notre à notre
émission je voudrais qu'on parle du du
de la qualité débatteur tiens peut-être
de de Gabriel Atal je me tourne vers
vous adéïd zulficarptitic parce que on a
moi j'ai le souvenir euh c'est peut-être
ces premières armes en en politique on
est je crois en décembre 2018 quand le
l'Arc de Triomphe est saccagé par des
des gilets jaunes il y à nos confrères
de France Télé de France 2 qui monte un
débat un peu dans dans l'urgence il se
retrouve face à Jean-Luc Mélenchon et et
d'autres et là il se révèl euh
ça est-ce que comment c'est perçu par
les Français je ce que je veux dire
c'est un peu c'est quelque chose qui qui
infuse qui est directement ressenti
c'est comment ça peut être perçu ça un
homme politique qui ou une femme
politique qui sait débattre qui va au
combat ouais j'allais dire c'est
peut-être pas tant le fait qu' qu'il
débatte que le fait qu'il soit qu'il a
une sorte de courage de de descendre
dans l'arine et de prendre la parole et
de défendre ses convictions par beaucoup
de ministres qui avaient cétait placé
aux abonnés Absen exactement et c'est
des qualités qui lui sont reconnu parce
qu'on le disait tout à l'heure c'est
Stéphane Vernet qui disait en fait
je pense qu'il va imprimer quelque chose
il donne l'impression d'être en capacité
de prendre des décisions qui s'imposent
et c'est effectivement quand on regarde
un petit peu les traits d'images
détaillé sur lequel il est évalué c'est
quelque chose qui lu est effectivement
reconnu les Français nous disent dans
les dans les dans les qualités qui sont
les les plus reconnus alors outre le
fait qu'il est sympathique on juge une
certaine compétence on nous dit qu'il
est capable de prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent et effectivement c'est pas
tant le caractère encore une fois sa
qualité de débatteur que cette espèce de
courage cette audace et et il donne
l'impression de de quelqu'un
effectivement alors il donne aussi
l'impression d'avoir des convictions
d'être en capacité de les défendre avec
une certaine dose d'honnêteté et de
sincérité en revanche j'aimerais juste
compléter parce que tout à l'heure on
disait on montrait le portage où il
allait son premier déplacement en tant
que Premier ministre on disait il
incarne enfin en tout cas il essaie
d'incar d'incarner une forme de
proximité c'est pas quelque chose que
les Français lui reconnaissent en tout
cas c'est pas une de ses qualités
premières on a j'ai une quinzaine de
très d'images sur lesquelles on l'
évalué c'est quelque chose qui ressort
quandême un petit peu en retrait par
rapport à justement ces notions à la
fois de compét d'honnêteté de sincérité
la proximité c'est quelque chose qu'on
reconnaî davantage en c aujourd'ui à
Marine Le Pen qu'AB tal mais voilà donc
c'était pour nuancer un petit peu ce ce
portrait alors on a évoqué la la la
question de finalement la colonne
vertébrale un peu idéologique d'un d'un
Gabriel Atal Stéphane Vernet qu'est-ce
que vous en dites de ça pour la
communication tout le monde est d'accord
il est très bon ok et on va on va le le
jauger ou le juger à l'ôe de Matignon où
il faut prendre parti sur tous les
sujets mais justement est-ce qu'il y a
une colonne vertébrale idéologique alors
on en parlait onvoqua aussi tout à
l'heure sur le côté est-ce qu'il est à
gauche est-ce qu'il est à droite ils
viennent à gauche et ce moi je pense je
pense qu'en fait il est il est euh euh
je pense qu'il est il est très
macroniste il est très pragmatique et en
fait il s'inscrit aussi dans une société
qui est en train de changer et qui qui
qui qui tend de plus en plus vers la
droite et je pense que l'intelligence de
de de Gabriel Atal et une de un de ses
talents c'est de c'est de c'est d'avoir
ce sens politique et de et de comment
dire de sentir les choses ou de les
flairer et son discours il est aussi
très adapté à un certain nombre
d'attentees de l'air du temps je voilà
donc sur des sur le besoin d'autorité de
fermeté sur la loi immigration on l'a
peut-être pas beaucoup entendu mais je
mais il faisait pas partie des des des
frondeurs ou des gens qui avaient des
réserves sur le sujet donc en fait il a
eu raison sinon il serait pas mettre
exactement non mais enfin je veux dire
il il est je pense qu'il va je je je
pense qu'il a ce cet instinct qui lui
permet d'aller dans le sens du vent et
le sens du vent et je suis désolé de
vous le dire aujourd'hui en France il
est il est plutôt sou il sou
plutô je penseon en est tous conscient
et on est on est tous d'accord là après
après
euh donc il insiste beaucoup sur le pour
lui le le son public clé et il il l'a
dit dans le petit extrait que vous avez
publié sur sur c'est quand il est dans
le pour lui c'est la clé de 2027 c'est
la clé de l'élection de 2027 c'est aussi
ce que Marine Le Pen a compris depuis
longtemps
en fait ils sont ils sont c'est là que
c'est intéressant c'est que dans le dans
le sa capacité à débattre vous parliez
tout à l'heure Émilie vous parliez du du
match des trentenaires avec Jordane
Bardella je pense qu'on est vraiment au
au au cœur du truc c'estàdire que c'est
c'est la personne qu' faut en fait pour
réussir à limiter la casse aux
prochaines aux prochaines élections
européennes il a parlez on le voit
d'ailleurs dans dans le Pas de
calaisette cette capacité là ou il me
semble il me semble qu'il a parce qu'on
parle souvent du clone d'Emmanuel Macron
mais il a cette capacité vous l'avez dit
d'intuition un petit peu plus de sentir
ce qui est dans la société et ce que les
gens souhaitent et c'est vrai que je
suis pas sûr qu'il y a une colonne
vertébrale mais en tout cas c'est l'idée
de s'adapter à ce qui est attendu
fortement et autre chose je pense qu'il
est beaucoup plus authentique sincère
alors vous avez dit pas la proximité
mais l'authenticité et je pense que ça
ça marque c'est-à-dire je comprends ce
que vous dites je suis avec vous même si
c'est pas une proximité mais d'une
sincérité et ça c'est important parce
que Marine Le Pen a gagné une partie du
cœur des français grâce à ça en disant
je je me place à côté de vous dans votre
vie au quotidien de quoi vous avez
besoin et je pense que lui contrairement
à Emmanuel Macron il peut jouer cette
carte là Emmanuel Macron on sait jamais
exactement et une des grandes forces de
Gabriel Atal c'est quand il parle on
comprend ce qu'il
dit vous avez un certain nombre de de
ministres de politique et même le
président de la République d'une
certaine manière je suis désolé mais
dans le dans le dans les termes utilisés
des formules et cetera le discours
parfois il y a y a ça matche pas il y a
un truc qui colle pas et une des
qualités de Gabriel hatal c'est que
c'est que au moins c'est simple et ça
pour le coup c'est aussi une qualité
qu'à Marine Le Pen et encore une fois on
revientent au match revent au match
quand il était porte-parole du
gouvernement ce que nous disaient les
Français dans les enquêtes c'est il est
très clair il a un sens de la pédagogie
pour nous expliquer les choses de
manière très cétait ça fonctionnait bien
alors il y a une autre facette de
Gabriel hatal c'est son homosexualité il
ne la porte pas en étand d'ARD mais il
l'assume complètement l'association SOS
Homophobie aujourd'hui se réjouit je les
cite hein du fait qu'être homosexuel ou
gay aujourd'hui ne soit plus un obstacle
à l'exercice de fonction de premier rang
la société progresse cette visibilité va
dans le bon sens ce qui est important
toutefois rajoute SOS Homophobie ce sont
les actes et les politiques menées nous
attendons un gouvernement qui prend à
bras le corp la question des violence et
des agressions contre les personnes
LGBTI et agissent concrètement pour
l'égalité des droits c'est aussi l'une
des infos du jour flan Gabriel altal
Premier ministre premier Premier
ministre gay de la 5e République on y
voit une marque de progrès on peut le
dire sans voilà simplement en tout cas
on y voit une absence de conservatisme
c'est déjà pas mal oui c'est déjà pas
mal mais je je je pense qu'il a été très
discret sur sa vie privée il a il en a
parlé que lorsque d'autres l'ont obligé
à en parler l'extrême droite et Ran
Branco il en a parlé avec pondération et
et je pense que c'est important de
rester sur cette réserve qu'il a
appliqué et qui n'est ni un marqueur
politique favorable ni un marqueur
politique défavorable donc j'ai vu que
certains médias effectivement faisait
des éléments importants je pense que ça
ne définit pas une personne ça ne
définit pas une politique éid et et je
crois qu'il faut il a réussi sur ce
point-là à être à peu près pondéré et je
pense que ça serait appréciable que on
reste tous sur cette pondération pour ne
pas faire de sa vie privée un élément en
sa faveur ou en sa défaveur même si
c'est pour ça que ce sera pas le
chapitre essentiel de ce débat on est on
est bien d'accord mais quand même un mot
un mot là-dessus parce que vous disiez
et c'est vrai que ça a été son choix une
forme de discrétion sauf que quand on
est premier ministre AD FP si on on peut
plus quoi c'estàd que les photos de
famille de Paris Match c'est un peu un
passage obligé il va peut-être réussir à
échapper mais est-ce que ça vous semble
compliqué quand on construit une
carrière de premier plan d'échapper à
cette dimionitante parce que après
effectivement on parle de d'orientation
sexuelle et pas parce que je je pensais
spontanément il y a pas de comparatif
mais à la vie privée de François
mitteran on a on savait tous qu'il avait
une F caché et cet envie de dire pas un
sujet pas la même époque mais c'est pas
non plus je sais pas si c'est un sujet
pour les Françis en toute honnêteté
jusqu'à présent effectivement il a
réussi à cette cette ascension
fulgurante dans l'opinion il est passé
de 15e classement des personnalités
préférées à 3e donc on voit bien que
c'est à mon avis c'est un non sujet
comme vous l'avez dit je pense que voilà
et peut-être est-ce que la soci je pense
que la société française est mû pour ça
aujourd'hui euh voilà pour le coup je
pense que c'est quand même discutif on a
on a un président qui avait même pas 40
ans quand il est devenu président on a
eu une femme Premier ministre ça faisait
quand même 30 ans qu'on attendait ça on
a un Premier ministre qui a 34 ans qui
très très jeune et qui moi je mettrai
tout dans le même panier c'est-à-dire
c'est quand même des choses très
nouvelles que Emmanuel Macron nous
apporte ça fait pas pour a un cap
politique non ça fait pas un cap
évidemment mais c'est quand même des
choses modernes là il y a une adaptation
à la société dans laquelle on vit alors
est- ce qui est frappant enanche c'est
que malgré cette modernité vous avez
parl aussi de sa communication sur les
réseaux sociaux il est pas beaucoup plus
populaire chez les jeunes au contraire
ça sa courbe de popularité elle
progresse avec l'âge des Français il a
parce qu'il a une structure
très macronienne exactement tout à fait
euh Gabriel natal nommé donc Premier
ministre un peu après midi il va falloir
attendre encore un peu hein pour avir le
gouvernement je propose à Tam la Nui de
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau euh
bonsoir Tam bienvenu bonsoir vous
allevez regardé un peu dans dans dans le
rétro il va falloir attendre quelques
jours c'est ça oui hein les spéculations
vont encore pouvoir aller bon train
quelques jours la fumée blanche est
attendue pour la fin de semaine alors je
me suis amusée effectivement à regarder
dans le retto regarder comment ça s
s'était passé depuis 2017 alors je
regardais uniquement les premiers
gouvernements des nouveaux premiers
ministres alors premier gouvernement
d'Édouard Philippe le Premier ministre
est nommé le 15 mai 2017 et il faut
attendre et bien 2 jours le 17 mai pour
voir son gouvernement nommé premier
gouvernement de Jean Castex le Premier
ministre est nommé le 3 juillet 2020 le
gouvernement et bien le 6 juillet il
faut attendre donc un jour de plus 3
jours et puis ellisabeth borne première
ministre nommé le 16 mai 2022 le
gouvernement il faut attendre 4 jours le
20 mai al je sais pas si c'est une
tendance pour la suite du il quoi nous
tenir en haline nous les journalistes
politiques et surtout les chaînes d'info
en continue oui alors pourquoi c'est
aussi long alors il y a des explications
oui il y a il y a des choses
rationnelles bon déjà sans doute parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron maître des horloges
aime prendre son temps mais aussi parce
qu'il y a eu des affaires qui ont
ébranlé la confiance des Français dans
leur dirigeants politiques qui ont donné
lieu à de nouveaux contrôles sur ses
personnalités comment ne pas citer
l'affaire kusac en 2013 qui a engendré
la création de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique la
fameuse hatvp et puis l'affaire Fillon
qui a fait de la moralisation de la vie
politique l'un des axes de la première
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron de 2017 qui a
eu pour conséquence la loi pour la
confiance dans la vie politique et
d'ailleurs depuis 2017 et bien les
ministres pressentis doivent si possible
montrer pte blanche avant d'être nommé
ça explique donc ce délai comment ça se
passe le président de la République il
demande à la h TVP de transmettre les
informations dont elle dispose sur
toutes ses personnalités c'est le cas
notamment quand les membres pressentis
sont des élus ou sont des responsables
publics donc ça marche forcément moins
bien si le ministre pressenti vient du
privé on fait voilà on fait un premier
scanner de la situation du futur
ministre en terme de patrimoine
d'intérêt le président peut aussi
demander l' à l'administration fiscale
une attestation qui concerne le paiement
des impôts du candidat et puis enfin il
peut aussi consulter son casier
judiciaire et ce n'est pas le seul
contrôle effectué par cette Haute
Autorité oui il y a un autre contrôle
dont on entend souvent beaucoup parler
un contrôle plus approfondi puisque tous
les ministres doivent remettre des
déclarations complètes de patrimoine
d'intérêt dans les de mois qui suivent
leur nomination et là la hatvp passe
tout au crible elle vérifie si tout est
exact sincère exhaustif elle vérifie les
conflits d'intérêts possibles ce
contrôle il est tout sauf anodin en une
dizaine d'années parmi ses célèbres
victimes Thomas tevenou et sa phobie
administrative le raflé celle AC ce
ministre des sports mais aussi Alain
Griset ou encore la dernière enend dat
et bien c'était Caroline cailleux sortie
après des soupçons de sous-évaluation de
sa déclaration de patrimoine du coup 2
mois pour faire sa déclaration à la
achatavp quand on devient ministre et
bien c'est trop long selon la Haute
Autorité hein son président Didier Migot
dans son rapport annuel d'avril dernier
a préconisé une nouvelle mesure que les
ministres mettent dès la première
semaine un questionnaire de prévention
des conflits d'intérêts parce qu'un
délai trop long peut je cite nuire à
l'action du gouvernement confère et bien
les exemples que j'ai que je vous ai dit
noté que les membres sortants du
gouvernement et donc ellisabeth band par
exemple va aussi devoir déposer une
déclaration de situation patrimoniale de
fin de mandat également dans les de mois
elle qui quitte donc Matignon pour
l'assemblée merci beaucoup Tam donc on
va se préparer psychologiquement à
attendre quelques jours Stéphane Vernet
il y a enfin o il y avait dans le
gouvernement de ab borne a un certain
nombre de de poids lourd et peut-être
que en tout cas en terme de
popularité Gabriel en faisait partie
est-ce que ça va comment je peux dire ça
ça peut être compliqué psychologiquement
pour on va citer un Gérald Arman un
Bruno Leem de se retrouver d'un seul
coup sous les ordres d'un jeune premier
ministre alors ça peut mais je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la question en fait
enfin moi
je je
je on leur on a dit beaucoup de choses
sur le sujet et cetera enfin voilà mais
moi je je je je je pense pas que ce soit
un problème h euh je pense que ça va se
jouer à un autre à un autre un autre
niveau c'est pas la question de savoir
euh est-ce
que Gabriel Attal est trop jeune pour
diriger une équipe et cetera tout
l'intérêt de de ce qui va être de ce qui
va être monté c'est euh c'est la c'est
le le le périmètre des ministères qui
vont être définis et le choix des gens
qui vont être mis en place pour les
diriger et le leur autonomie leur de
manœuvre par rapport par rapport à
l'Élysée et par rapport à Matignon
et je je ne crois pas que la jeunesse de
de Gabriel soit un soucici ce qui moi ce
qui me fait rigoler dans ce qu'on entend
beaucoup dans la bouche les uns et les
autres c'est l'idée c'est de dire alors
ça ça vient de l'Élysée ça vient de
certains ministres ça vient plein de G
qui plein de gens qui étudient la
situation qui disent oui c'est le moment
d'avoir un gouvernement
resserré un petit quelques ministres des
choses des grands pôles des choses très
efficaces et cetera et à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'on dit à chaque fois cha
fois ça finit à 40 voilà il y en aura
que 10 et et au moment où on on découvre
la liste ils sont 40 45 ou 47 et
pourquoi d'ailleurs c'est impossible de
d'avoir votre avis là-dessus en radio
parce que parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre de alors j'allais dire lobby mais
pas seulement quoi qui s'expriment en
disant là là comment est-ce possible
nous n'avons pas de ministère dédié il y
y a de ça al d'abord il faut mettre au
moins un ministère par administration ou
plusieurs administrations sur le
ministère donc il y a des périmètres qui
sont d'ors et déjà figés ensuite vous
avez effectivement des thématiques qui
ne peuvent pas être en deséran sans quoi
vous avez certes des lobes mais sinon
une perception d'un désintérêts pour un
sujet enfin vous avez aussi des courants
surtout quand vous avez une majorité
plurielle composite que vous êtes obligé
de remercier d'envoyer des signaux plus
ou moins positifs et donc évidemment
chaque chef de parti chaque chef de
courant veut que so mootion son courant
soit le plus représenté possible et donc
additionner des plus et des plus à la
fin ça fait des gouvernements à 43 ou 45
ministres avec des ministres des
ministres délégués et des secrétaires
d'État ouais et des poids lourds qui
veulent à priori rester il y en a un en
tout cas qui l'a dit c'est Gérald
armanin ministre de l'intérieur c'est
quelques minutes après la nomination de
Gabriel hatal à matigon écoutons je
pense que chacun a vu que je n'avais pas
fini ma mission au ministère de
l'Intérieur et que je ne suis pas homme
à me dérober quand il y a des policiers
des gendarmes des préfets qui a quelques
jours on est à 100 jours du relais de la
flamme on est à 200 jours des Jeux
Olympiques vont risquer leur vie mettre
leur réputation en jeu moi je suis un
homme d'honneur je suis un homme de
devoir et vous savez de là où je viens
d'une province une famille populaire on
aime bien terminer ce qu'on fait voilà
après il appartient au président de la
République de disposer évidemment des
postes ministériels je suis à sa
disposition mais je veux dire aux
policiers aux gendarmes que je n'ai pas
l'habitude de compter sur un quelconque
avenir personnel lorsque je les ai
engagé dans une voix et il zapalski
spécialiste de la com est-ce queil y a
pas une marque de fébrilité un peu un
petit peu c'est un peu caricaturel quand
même hein de de lancer tous ses
arguments jusqu'à rappeler son profil
personnellement ou quoi oui c'est une
maladresse mais ça correspond quand même
au style globalement de Gérald armanin
qui va quand même un peu de manière très
directe peut-être que ça marche moi ce
que j'ai remarqué dans la communication
de Gérald armanin c'est que la plupart
du temps ses erreurs ne lui collent pas
à la peau donc finalement il a raison
peut-être d'avancer de manière très
directe et c'est vrai que ces derniers
temps il a quand même beaucoup donné
même s'il a échoué sur la loi
immigration à créé des alliances adelï
zulfi CARPA est-ce que pour autant un
Emmanuel Macron peut se passer de ses
poids lourds quoi il y en a pas tant que
ça il y en a plus beaucoup effectivement
dans le gouvernement après en terme un
Bruno lomer par exemple je je vois ENF
je pense qu'il a quand même plutôt
intérêt à le à le conserver Gérard
Darmanin il a il a cert beaucoup moins
il est beaucoup moins populaire dans
l'opinion que Gabriel Atal mais mais
néanmoins on lu reconnaît certaines
qualités notamment sur les sujets qui
sont les siens les questions justement
de sécurité il a réussi quand même à à
imposer plus ou moins sa marque et c'est
vrai que il l'a dit lui-même et c'est
quand même une réalité il y a les Jeux
Olympiques qui sont un gros enjeu pour
la France dans 6 mois il gère la
sécurité depuis maintenant plusieurs
enfin depuis
longtemps donc effectivement il y a
toute je pense queemmanuel Macron et je
pense pas en plus que les Français alors
cert les Français attendaient quand même
globalement on l'avait testé en décembre
il était les de tiers à réclamer un
changement de Premier ministre mais
c'était aussi à C de la séquence
retraite qui avait quand même beaucoup
affaibli la première ministre et plus la
loi immigration qui ne sit pas passer
exactement comme on le souhaitait pour
autant je ne pense pas que les Français
attendent vraiment un remanimement de
grande ampleur et je crois d'ailleurs
qu'ils attendent rien du tout enfin je
je pense qu'on en parle nous beaucoup
ici mais je suis pas certaine que ils en
parlent autant que nous Stéphane Vernet
il y a une question de coulisse comment
ça va se passer pour un journaliste
politique comour là les quelques jours
qui viennent c'est qu'on va vous
abreuver de fauses vraies rumeurs vous
allez essayer de savoir qui qui va où
alors c'est c'est la phase où tout le
monde il y a plein de gens qui prêche le
faux pour savoir le vrai et viers ça
donc il y a moi je pense que vous avez
un certain nombre de de gens dont le
téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner ù vous
avez des amis de 10 ans de 20 ans de 30
ans qui se rappellent à votre bon
souvenir donc je pense que la pression
elle va plutôt être du côté du côté des
du du du côté de de de de Gabriel hatal
et de son entourage nouveau de son
cabinet qui formé ou plutôt à l'Élysée
d'ailleurs et puis et puis vous avez
plein de gens qui font circuler des oui
des des des rur des vrais ou des fausses
informations on a les ballons desess et
cetera mais toute façon enfin moi je par
rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit moi je
suis à peu près sûr que Géral lmanin va
rester en poste parce qu'effectivement
vous changez pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur juste avant les les JO Bruno
Lemer restaurant au poste et je vois mal
ouais je vois mal arriver des gens de la
société civile parce que je vous
rappelle que le précédent ranimement en
fait a consisté à virer tous les gens
qui ou presque qui vent la société
civile sur il y a pas 10000 spécialistes
merci beaucoup votre livre déjeuner
secret dans les couliss de la réforme
des retraites aux éditions West France
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat à bientôt sur Public Sénat